This is Flight 372 on SWA.
The flight attendants on board serving you today:...
...Theresa in the middle, David in the back.
My name is David and I'm here to tell you that...
...shortly after takeoff, first things first,...
...there are soft drinks and coffee to quench your thirst...
...but if you want another kind of drink then just holler.
Alcoholic beverages, that'll be four dollars.
If a Monster Energy Drink is your plan,...
...that'll be three dollars and you get the whole can.
We won't take your cash, you gotta pay with plastic.
If you have a coupon, then that's fantastic.
We know you're ready to get to new places.
Open up the bins, put away your suitcases.
Carry-on items go under the seat...
...in front of you, so none of you have things by your feet.
If you have a seat on a row with the exit,...
...we're gonna talk to you so you might as well expect it.
You gotta help evacuate in case we need you,...
...if you don't wanna then we're gonna reseat you.
Before we leave, our advice is put away your electronic devices.
Fasten your seatbelt, then put your trays up.
Press the button to make the seat back raise up.
Sit back, relax, have a good time.
It's almost time to go, so I'm done with the rhyme.
Thank you for the fact that I wasn't ignored.
This is Southwest Airlines. Welcome aboard!